[موسيقى]
ام
اهلا بكم قالت رئيسه لجنه الاستخبارات في
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي ان اللجنه ستبدا
عمليه اعاده تقييم واسعه لعمليات التجسس
الامريكيه واكدت رفضها اي عمليات تجسس قد
تطال قاده الدول الحليفه لواشنطن
ياتي ذلك بعد غضب اوروبي بعد اكتشاف تنصت
امريكي على قاده اوروبيين نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقشه في محورين ما حجم وطبيعه
الاضرار التي لحقت بعلاقه واشنطن والعواصم
الاوروبيه من جراء ازمه التجسس
وما بقدره الجانبين على تجاوز الازمه
الحاليه وعلى التخلص من اثارها المستقبليه
على التعاون بينهما
منذ انتخاب عملياتها التجسسيه التي طالت
زعماء خمس وثلاثين دوله حليفه والولايات
المتحده تعيش جدلا في داخلها واخر مع
الخارج بشان طبيعه ونطاق عملها
الاستخباراتي في العالم وبموازاه جلسه
لجنه الاستخبارات في مجلس النواب الامريكي
يستجوب خلالها مدير وكاله الامن القومي
الجنرال كيث الكسندر حول هذه القضيه
يستقبل مسؤولون امريكيون اخرون اسئله
واستفسارات وفد اوروبي يزور واشنطن حاليا
لاستجلاء ابعاد ما تعرضت له القاره العجوز
من استخبارات اقرب حلفائها
لم ينجو من تجسس هم احد حتى الحلفاء فلا
حصانه لدول ورؤساء ناهيك عن الافراد
والمؤسسات ذلك ما يتكشف يوما بعد اخر
ملايين الاتصالات الهاتفيه خضعت للتنصت
عبر العالم من بينها بحسب صحيفه الغارديان
البريطانيه هواتف زعماء خمس وثلاثين دوله
ابرز هؤلاء كانت المستشاره الالمانيه
انجيلا ميركل ورئيسه الوزراء الاسبانيان
السابق والحل وفي التفاصيل التي اوردتها
صحف ومجلات المانيه واوروبيه فان هناك
وحدات تجسس امريكيه في ثمانين موقع حول
العالم من بينها المانيا و باريس ومدريد
وروما وبراد وجنيف
في برلين حيث لا تبعد السفاره الامريكيه
عن مكتب ميركل اكثر من ثمانمائه متر توجد
واحده من هذه الوحدات يتمركز فيها عاملون
منو كالتي المخابرات المركزيه والطيران
والفضاء ناسا
يجمعون المعلومات كما قال تدريس بيقل
مستعينين باجهزه حديثه اما صحيفه بيلد
تضيفه بان هؤلاء كانوا يرسلون معلوماتهم
مباشره الى البيت الابيض وليس الى مقر
وكاله الامن القومي وشملت تجسس حسب
الصحيفه كل شيء الرسائل النصيه ال ميركل
وهاتفها النقال ولم يسلم سوى هاتفها
الثابت المشفر في مقر المستشاريه ورغم نفي
البيت الابيض علم اوباما بهذا الا ان
برلين استدعت السفير الامريكي لديها
ومثلها فعلت مدريد وسعه المستشاره
الالمانيه والرئيس الفرنسي خلال القمه
الاوروبيه الاخيره في تيار عام ومراجعه
الاتفاقات الامنيه مع واشنطن في هذا
الخصوص وطلبت اولا من واشنطن عقد اتفاق
يمنع التجسس مع نهايه هذا العام الاتحاد
الاوروبي بدوره ارسل وفدا من المشرعين الى
الولايات المتحده للاستيضاح والبحث بينما
تسعى بعض الدول لتحصين قاعده بيانات
مواطنيها ومؤسساتها ما قد يؤثر على حريه
وتدفق المعلومات عبر العالم
الاضطرار على ذلك بل انه عصف بالعلاقات
الامريكيه الاوروبيه ما يستدعي اجراءات
لترميم الثقه الاعتذارات كما قال قاده
اوروبيون
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا في
الاستوديو الكاتب والباحث السياسي
الالماني غيدو شتاينبيرغ ومن واشنطن
روبيرت المحلل السابق لدى وكاله
الاستخبارات الامريكيه السي اي ايه ومن
باريس الدكتور خطار ابو دياب الباحث في
المعهد الدولي للدراسات
الجيوسياسيه اهلا بكم جميعا وابدا ما
رويال غير سؤال فضولي
اه ونحن نتحدث الان ربما في نفس الوقت
يدافع مدير وكاله الامن القومي الامريكي
امام لجنه الاستخبارات في اه الكونغرس عن
ان تنص الامريكي حمايه لا من الامريكيين
لكن هل لك ان تشرح لنا عندما تتجسس على
الهاتف الشخصي ل انجيلا ميركل كيف تحول من
الامريكيين
في الحقيقه سيعتمد هذا على ما اذا كانت
السيده
منخرطه في نقاشات اه قد تكون معارضه او
معاليه للمصالح الامريكيه التي تذكر ان
السيده ميركل وصلت الى السلطه سنه الفين
وخمسه
والنشاطات
الالماني في اه في العراق وكانت في
الحقيقه المتعاونه اكثر من اه
جيرهارد شرويدر
وايضا اه اه النظر الى نشاطاته ضد اه
امريكا في العراق
هل نفهم من ذلك ان ما نقل اكثر
تشددا لكن لناخذ مثلا ليبيا عندما كان
الالمان ضد المشاركه والمشاركه في العمليه
في ليبيا وكانت ضد الموقف الامريكي لم يكن
هذا الامر عدائيا لكنهم لم بالتاكيد لم
يدعمون او كان من الممكن ان هم كان هنالك
ربما حوادث او حالات
قبل الرئيس الامريكي يريد ان يعرف ما الذي
تفكر فيه المستشاره ميركل فيما يتعلق
بالعمليه في ليبيا مثلا
ولكن اوباما نفى علمه
اه س اقول ان ال الرئيس ربما كان على ال
من طفيفه بالموضوع يعني هو كذب على ميركل
عندما قال لها انا لا اتفق عليه
انا اقول فقط
قانونا عندما اه يكون هناك اعتراضات من
وكاله الامن القومي والامر يتعلق ب اه
امور مستقبليه و معلومات تتعلق بالبيت
الابيض انا تشكك من ان الرئيس لم يكن على
علم
بهذه الاعتراضات ذات المستوى العالي
المتعلقه بالمانيا طبعا
السيد اغيد وستين كما رايك بما قاله
في الاستخبارات الامريكيه ضيفي من واشنطن
هل باعتقادك اه ما قاله صحيح من ناحيه
تريد ان يعلم ما الذي تفكر فيه بنسبه
ليبيا هل حصل فعلا على المعلومات هل كان
فعلا العين تصير كما استخدم التعبير ضيفي
الكريمين واشنطن
لان هذا الهاتف كان الهاتف الشخصي ميركل
والهاتف لكل ال ال ال المسائل الحزبيه
فكان يتصل بهذا الهاتف مع السياسيين
الالمان الى الى حد ما اه حياتها الشخصيه
فليست علاقه ليس ليس ليس هناك علاقه بين
هذه الاتصالات انجيلا ميركل والامن القومي
الامريكي
اه بما بما لها هاتف جوال اخر في داخل
المس اه ال مستشاريه لكي تتكلم اه
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الفرنسي
اشخاص اخرين من يهتم فعلا بالسياسه
الالمانيه ال ال الخارجيه هو يهتم ب ال ال
اه الموظفين المهمين في ال ال مستشاريه
انا استغرب لماذا فعلا اه كانت
الاستخبارات الامريكيه تهتم بهذا اه ال
الهاتف وانا شخصيا اعتقد ان اه الرئيس
اوباما ما كان اه اه ما كان يعرف ماذا حدث
اه هناك لانه كل هذا كل هذا صدمه كبيره في
العلاقات بين المانيا اه وامريكا و اه
وهذا كان كان واضح من البدايه دكتور خطار
ابو دياب صدمه كبيره اذا وسميت ايضا في
فضيحه التجسس
ما تقييمك حجم الاضرار التي لحقت ب على
العلاقات الاوروبيه مع واشنطن
نعم هي صدمه وهي فضيحه اه الكل يقول في
البدايه الكل يتجسس على ال كل هذا الكلام
صحيح كل جهاز تجسس
جمع المعلومات والتفتيش على الخبر لكن في
هذه المساله بالذات منذ بليكس حتى سنو ان
هناك نوع من ال استباحه الامريكيه تظهر
بجلاء بمعنى او باخر لان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي تفوقت تكنولوجيا ورقيا على
غيرها بالاشواط عندها الكثير من عناصر
القوه لكن فائض القوه هذا لا يخدم وها
وكانه لا يكفيها وعندها الشهيه دائما
الحصول على المعلومه فيما يخص ميركل
بالذات على ما يبدو هذا التنصت بدا منذ
العام الفين واثنين اي عندما كانت زعيمه
الحزب المعارض واستمر
الرئيس اوباما بالذات اخذ علما بذلك في
العام الفين وعشره وهنا الطامه الكبرى
مصداقيه الرئيس اوباما هي على المحك
بالفعل لم يكن صادقا مع نظرائه الاوروبيين
ومع الحلفاء هو يعلم بكل شيء هو الى الحكم
تحت عنوان داعيه الحقوق المدنيه كان يريد
اغلاق وان تنامي وحمايه الحريات الشخصيه
فانه ان عبر الطائرات من دون طيار او عبر
تغطيه هذا الكم الهائل من عمليات التجسس
تسعين دوله في العالم تسعه عشر مركز في
اوروبا لوحدها نتكلم عن بيكبر اثير عن
كمياتها الى من التجسس واظن ان كل ذلك لا
يخدم صوره امريكا في العالم وان هذا
التصدع الذي حصل سيكون من الصعب جدا اعاده
وصله بسهوله هنا الدكتور استغل وجودك طرف
عربي معناها اسالك سؤال على الهامش هنا
فقط ربما هناك من يشاهدون او يطرح علامات
استفهام اذا كانت الولايات المتحده التجسس
على حلفاءها الاوروبيين طبيعه حاليا تتجسس
على دول عربيه اخرى اليس كذلك
لم نجد من اه اه يهدف من هؤلاء ال زعماء
الدول العربيه يقولون لما تتجسس او
يستدعون سفير او يرفعون هذه القضيه
تعليقك على هذه الملاحظه
حتى الان تبرعت صحيفه لوموند
وكشفت المستور لانسان قبل لجوئه الى روسيا
قام بتسليم معلوماته واصراره الى الصحف
برازيل كان يعمل في الغارديان والان
يتعاون مع لوموند وبعد ذلك انتقلت المساله
الى درجه كيلو صحف اسبانيه حتى الان على
ما يبدو الكنز المتعلق بالعالم العربي و
بدول اخرى لم يصل الى وسائل الاعلام لكن
من الاكيد حسب المتداول ان مليارات
الرسائل النصيه والمخابرات وان كل القاده
العرب كل البلدان العربيه خاضعه لتسلط
وكاله الامن القومي الامريكي هناك اشياء
يمكن ان تبرر تحت غطاء مكافحه الارهاب لكن
هناك امور في الحياه الشخصيه كما هناك
تدخل في الحريات العامه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه امام الفوضى الاستراتيجيه في
العالم وامام عالم نتخبط متعدد الاقطاب
انها تريد الحصول على معلومات افضل لانها
في خلل هناك خللا في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه
اذا راينا علاقات اوباما مع اوروبا
علاقاته مع دول اسيا وهو لم يحضر القمه
الاخيره مع انه كان يقول باهميه الرجوع
الى اسيا والمحيط الهادئ اذا راينا
علاقاته في مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
كما حصل حديثا نفهم جيدا الصعوبه في بلوره
السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
وهذا الخلل الاستخباري هو خلل جزئي من
مجموع الخلل العام في السياسه الامريكيه
اه ضيفي من واشنطن
ما الذي يمكن ان تقوله واشنطن للوفد
الاوروبي حاليا الذي يستفسر يستفسر منا او
واشنطن من مسؤولين امريكيين عما حدث
الحقيقه انا لست متاكدا يقولون بان
الاوروبيين كانوا على معرفه اه
بنشاطات هي وكاله الامن القومي في اوروبا
لعقود وهذا الامر ليس بالجديد
للخدمات الاستخباراتيه قادره على تحديد اه
منشاه خاصه وكاله الامن القومي وهو الامر
وهي ليست فيه اه لذلك هم يعرفون اننا كنا
موجودون موجودين هناك وان ال اه ولذلك
البريطانيون مثلا يعرفون تماما اه ما يقوم
به الامريكيون وهذا جزء من الجهاز العلاقه
بين جهازي الاستخبارات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه ومره اخرى الفرنسيون ايضا
الذين لديهم نوع من ال اه الاستخدام
العدائي للتكنولوجيا
وهم يعرفون ايضا الاجراءات
لوكاله الامن القومي لذلك
النهايه اذا ما كان هنالك
قوانين جديده تتعلق بالهواتف النقاله
الشخصيه ل
للفرنسيين او للالمان يجب علينا ان ننتظر
ونرى
اعتقد لحد الان سيكون من الصعب للفرنسيين
والالمان بان يجادلون بان هم لديهم نفس
العلاقه مع الولايات المتحده كما هو الحال
بالنسبه للبريطانيين والكنديين
والاستراتيجيين والميادين من المحتمل هذا
امر محتمل لكن اعتقد ان العلاقه اه مع
الفرنسيين قد تغيرت وزادت قربا من الحرب
البارده والامر يطبقه على الالمان لكن
تامه هنالك اختلافات استراتيجيه بين
الامريكان وبين الفرنسيين والالمان سيكون
هنالك اه نوع من انواع المراقبه شكرا لك
ومعنا ضيوفي الكرام فاصل قصير نناقش بعده
مدى قدره الامريكيين والاوروبيين على
تجاوز اثار هذه الفضيحه فضيحه التجسس نرجو
ان تبقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
ام
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش بتداعيات قضيه التجسس الامريكي على
اوروبا امكانيه تجاوز تاثيراتها في
العلاقه بين الجانبين سيد جديده الى اي
مدى هنالك احراج في المانيا بسبب خرقها من
قبل الولايات المتحده بهذا الشكل وخلقت
بالراس فيها
وخاصه اه عند الحكومه والقسم المحافظ
الحزب المحافظ
كل هذا موضوع التجسس على الالمان او اه
على اه المجتمع ال اه اه العلماني كان مهم
في حمله الانتخابات وفي هذا العهد قبل
شهرين او ثلاثه اشهر
اه كان على حزب المحافظ
والمستشاره تدافع عن ال اه عن
الامريكيين وقالت ان هذه ال ال فضيحه قد
قد انتهت وبدا واضحا ان هذه الفضيحه اكبر
بكثير مما اعتقدنا وهناك في المانيا فهذه
مشكله مشكله كبيره الان وخاصه اه في
مفاوضات حول الائتلاف الجديد بين المعارضه
اه القديمه الاشتراكيين وال اه وال
والمحافظين ولكن فازت ال ال فاز الحزب
المحافظ في هذه الانتخابات وهذا كان
بالنسبه له ونسبه
للمستشاره اه ال المساله المهمه ولكن ربما
ستخسر اه بعض الاصوات في الانتخابات
القادمه وخاصه في دويلات ال اه المانيا
فهذه مشكله كبيره اه اه للمستشاره ولكن
خاصه في هذه ال في هذه المفاوضات الاعتراف
الان
داخليا
يمكن ان الولايات المتحده ان تدفعه لها
تعويضا
المشكله نسبه للمستشاره ميركل ان هناك
الكثير من الالمان يسالون نفسهم الان
هذه الفضيحه
انما تجسسوا الامريكيه على الكثيرين من
الالمان
اليوم والان عندما عندما يبدو واضحا
تجسسوا عليها الان هذه
هذه مساله داخليه بالنسبه لها ولكن بنفس
بنفس الوقت لا يمكنها ان الكثير من
الاشياء لان المخابرات الالمانيه
اه تعتمد اعتمادا كليا على مساعدات
الامريكيين وهذا
في الشرق الاوسط مثله مثل بريطانيا ولكن
هذه العلاقات
المخابرات الالمانيه
الالمانيه
الى حد كبير وخاصه في مكافحه الارهاب كان
هناك
البلاد قبل ست سنوات وكانت المعلومات
الاوليه من الامريكيين على ما يبدو هذا ما
حدث في كثير من التكتيكات الارهابيه
وبدا واضحا ان المخابرات الالمانيه
الالمانيه لا
هذه الظاهره الارهابيه في المانيا بدون
الامريكيين وهذه مشكله كبيره دكتور
الان الالماني على المساعده الامريكيه
المخابراتيه هل برايك تساعد على تخفيف
الضرر من جراء فضيحه التجسس
وينسحب ذلك ربما على بقيه الدول التي
عليها
اعتقد انه الموضوع هو على الشكل الاتي
اوروبا تدفع ثمن الكثير من التبعيه ازاء
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تصوروا انها
حجم ميزانيه ال الوكالات الاستخباريه
الامريكيه يصل الى حوالي خمسه وثلاثين
اربعين
دولار في السنه وكل ميزانيه الجيش الفرنسي
لا تصل الى هذا الرقم ميزانيه الابحاث في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اكبر بكثير
واكبر بعشرات المرات من الميزانيات
الاوروبيه اوروبا في تقصير ها في تحصين
نفسها ودفاعها تجد نفسها مشكله لكن هذه
ليست اعذار لان الاحترام المتبادل يجب ان
يسود بين الحلفاء
الاجهزه الامريكيه رغم كل هذا الكم هي
مقصره ولم تستطع ان تحمي الاراضي
الامريكيه من بعض العمليات الارهابيه اظن
ان هذه التبريرات كما قلت غير مقنعه ومن
هنا تطالب اوروبا الان باعاده النظر في
اساليب التعاون اما المانيا والبرازيل
ستدفع ان نحو تبني قرار في الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده من اجل حمايه الحريات اذن
فضيحه السودان او قضيه سنودن تاتي في لحظه
مناسبه من اجل عدم السماح للاذان الكبرى
ليس فقط الاذان الكبرى الامريكيه بل ربما
الاذان الامر الكبرى الروسيه والصينيه
والفرنسيه
والبريطانيه والالمانيه وغيرها من عدم
احترام حريه الناس واسقاط كل القيود هناك
مشكله كبيره ايضا في اه
الشركات التي تعمل على الانترنيت وعلى
اجهزه التواصل الاجتماعي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تسيطر على كل
على الفيس بوك عليه على كل هذه المعلمين
وهذا ومن هنا الان هناك يقضي المانيا مثلا
اخذت تخطط لانشاء مشغلات مستقله يمكن ان
يصبح هذا ايضا عمليه ممكنه في الصين في
فرنسا وغيرها اذن الولايات المتحده مع كل
هذه الشهيه وكل هذا الطموح وكل هذا الغرور
مع انها لم تعد القوه العظمى الوحيده ربما
من خلال هذا الاتفاق بدلا ان تعزز مواقعها
وتخدم اصدقائها ستكون ايضا خاسره على
المدى المتوسط
اه
رئيس الاستخبارات
في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي قالت انه سيجري
اعاده تقييم اه لمساله عمليات التجسس
الامريكيه هذه ولن يسمح بالتجسس على دول
حليفه الى اي حد هذا واقعي و قابل للتطبيق
في ظل كل ما قاله الدكتور خطار ابو دياب
عن هذه العالم الهائل من ال ال
الاستخبارات وال وما الى ذلك والى اي حد
يمكن ان هذه الخطوه انتم غضب الاوروبيين
واه
في الحقيقه اعتقد
ان اعاده التقييم قد يكون مفيدا
واعتقد انه من الجيد جدا ان نتاكد من
نوعيه المعلومات الاستخباريه التي نتلقاها
وخاصه اذا ما كانت موجهه ضد دول غربيه
لنرى اذا ما كانت المعلومات الحاصله التي
تبحث لينا عليها مختلفه من المعلومات التي
ربما اه تكون منشوره بشكل علمي انا لا
اعتقد في الحقيقه ان هذا سيستمر بطريقه
حقيقه اذا ما قمنا بمقارنه
ان مقام الفرنسيين بعام الفين وثلاثه ب اه
ربما اخذ موقف موقف مضاد والعمل ضدنا في
حرب العراق وضد البريطانيين
في ذلك الوقت نفسه فان العلاقات مع باريس
اصبحت مضطربه و متوتره وايضا العلاقات بين
الوكالات
وكالات الاستخبارات
الخارجيه
وكانت الاستخبارات الداخليه اه تعمقت بشكل
كبير بذلك اعتقد ان من الخطا ان اعتقد ان
هذا الحادث الذي لا يرقى الى مستوى ما حدث
في عام الفين وثلاثه في الحرب والعراق سوف
يعيد تشكيل العلاقات بين وكالات
الاستخباراتيه في الدول الغربيه كما
تعرفون مره اخرى اعتقد انه ليست بالفكره
السيئه ان يكون هنالك عمليه تقييم لكل
المعلومات الاستخباريه التي يتم جمعها من
الدول الغربيه وان اتساءل هل هي مفيده
وهل سيكون
ربما من الجيد في حاله ميركل
انه ليس من المهم جدا
لان المانيا اه كما تعرفون هي بلد منفتح
لذلك من الواضح اكس اقول بشكل شخصي سيكون
هنالك لكنني ساقول مره اخرى يجب اننا نقوم
ب اعاده تقييم المعلومات الاستخباريه وكما
تعرفون فان الكونغرس وللرئيس يجب ان يوافق
على هذا الامر وان نظرا الى الامر وان
يتوصل الى استنتاج ان الامر اه لا
ببساطه ليس له اي فائده واذا ما قالوا
اننا الامر يجب ان
السابق لدى وكاله اشكرك جزيل الشكر ايضا
اه اذكر دكتور خطار ابو دياب من باريس
الباحث مع دول الدراسات الجيوسياسيه واشكر
ستاينبيك الكاتب والباحث السياسي الالماني
كان معنا في الاستوديو اشكر متابعتكم
بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر
[موسيقى]
نعم